el mal palace at the foot of the Vettes
Tyne Mountains on Germany's southern
border
it's an enchanting location that
attracts not only tourists but some of
the world's finest musicians
[Music]
famous visitors have included Benjamin
Britten and London's legendary Amadeus
quartet and violin virtuoso Yehudi
Menuhin there are more than 200
top-flight evening concerts at el mal
palace every year mostly featuring jazz
and classical music
sometimes there's chamber music here
guests are treated to a quartet with
violinist Lisa Botticelli and violinist
Antoine Thomas tea chosen most Allah al
aliy al mal Palace is my favorite place
in the world time passes differently
here the air is different it's a world
unto itself musicians here don't get
paid their usual appearance fees instead
they get a couple of days free residents
including gourmet food because the food
is something essential for the artists
who come here for them everything
aesthetic and sensual is of the highest
importance they're the most discerning
guests the hotel can have a Hopf an
Hotel get
and the man in charge of the guests
culinary well-being is Mario corty he's
been el mal palaces executive chef since
2010 the hotel's flagship restaurant is
the luchador Oh a tiny gourmet eatery
seating 35 it's had a Michelin star for
several years
angle me destroys a gourmet restaurant
is great advertising for a complete
culinary concept
but corty is also responsible for
everything some 70 chefs serve in the
hotels eight other restaurants the
Copeland's is the internet we cook very
international food we don't want to
limit ourselves to any one style say
classic French with Euro Asian
influences etc we use seasonal products
we cook with passion using many
ingredients from the region deals kilo
Jose legume Co one of the most popular
dishes is filet of Vega beef with white
and green asparagus and potatoes
zum dama yet sons are weary have some
wonderful veggie you beef it comes from
our friends at Pretz at the German beg
you Academy it's 100% pure Vega beef
born and bred in Bavaria it's
wonderfully marbled its house a goatee
come back o preheat the oven to 90
degrees Celsius then bake the seared
meat for around 12 minutes then let it
stand briefly saute it again in butter
and you've got the perfect steak I'm
Spanish Bobby here's some grade-a
asparagus juicy and just harvested the
glossy limits you glaze the asparagus
very slowly with a bit of salt a pinch
of sugar and some poultry stock Shawn
done notice Gunter your chips cook
through very slowly in its own juices
he got so you're mine papa shooting a
cup off very have some nice potatoes
from the region you all cut into squares
we fry them slowly so that roasting
aromas can develop mama moobus is just
adding a little butter and some parsley
cherry tomatoes radishes some herbs and
a lug of good olive oil give the whole
thing some freshness let's keep them
dancin also named Dona Klein of Russia
philia vega beef with asparagus is a
luxurious dish the meat costs several
hundred euros a kilo
[Music]
the food and the music are a perfect
combination
a sister I can be Satan does money come
it's rare to spend the whole day in the
same place as the audience oh it's my 50
mention oh you meet people in the
restaurant in the spa around side when
toasty missus older sister yeah it feels
very natural very intimate the Fatah
it's fun sharing your music with these
people again if I need even mentioned
the fine food and fine music of el mal
castle are no secret enthusiasts flock
to this remote and enchanting location
you